[Musique]
malgré les bottes de pluie et les
sirènes les visiteurs étaient au rendez
vous pour assister à la seconde édition
de la garden party musicale de
versailles ce samedi 10 septembre
l'objectif de cette journée prolonger
l'été et ses activités dans un décor de
plage installée dans le domaine de
madame elisabeth alors c'est la deuxième
édition que l'on fait
donc l'idée cette année c'est de faire
encore plus de groupes encore plus de
choses et de penser encore plus allaiter
donc on a créé une plage avec des
transats c'est vraiment d'animations
autour de la plage de tout ce qu'on peut
avoir on a aussi un bar éphémère avec
des tatouages donc voilà tous les
activités qui peuvent vraiment nous
faire penser à l'été si les visiteurs
ont pu assister à des concerts tout au
long de la journée l'événement était
également l'occasion pour les artistes
de la région comme cloud hills d'aller à
la rencontre de leur public
[Musique]
et
c'est trop bien le combat et robots la
scène est trop belle les gens sont trop
cool les autres musiciens il déchire
d'encore une trop content en plus des
concerts de nombreux ateliers et
animations étaient proposées pour les
petits et les grands au programme des
initiations aux arts vivants des
ateliers de création ou encore des
activités sportives comme du volley ou
du maul qui une manière conviviale de se
retrouver en famille je suis venu
essentiellement pour ma fille du coup
pour profiter déjà du domaine et des
différentes activités qui sont proposées
donc c'est plutôt sympa puisqu'elle du
môle kia du badminton enfin on n'a pas
encore tous fait puisqu'on vient juste
d'arriver voilà donc c'est plutôt sympa
autant d'activités qui ont permis aux
visiteurs de passer un week-end de
rentrée aux allures de fin d'été